Namo tassa bhagavato hara-hatto samma-sambuddhassa Namo tassa bhagavato hara-hatto samma-sambuddhassa
Namo tassa bhagavato harahato sambha sambuddhasa Hommage to the Buddha, the blessed, noble and fully self-enlightened one.
Hier, je me suis concentré sur les principes de la méditation.
Aujourd'hui, je vais m'étendre sur les empêchements et sur la
la coproduction conditionnelle.
Si vous avez des questions au cours de la séance, vous pouvez les mettre par ici et les remettre derrière la porte.
À partir de 4 heures, nous aurons une séance de questions-réponses.
Dans notre condition d'être humain,
Et dans notre existence, pour le moment, c'est de ne pas savoir.
Parfois c'est traduit, disons, par le terme d'ignorance qui a une connotation péjorative.
Ce terme implique une faute pour ne pas, disons, de notre part, de ne pas savoir.
Cet état de ne pas savoir, disons avidja, est un état, disons, d'innocence.
Quand nous sommes nés, comment peut-on savoir ?
Pas beaucoup, hein ?
Et puis, nous commençons à apprendre, à recevoir des informations.
Et en tant qu'enfants, nous ne sommes pas en position de critiquer, remettre en question, disons, ces connaissances.
Alors, en tant qu'enfants, nous absorbons, disons, toutes les illusions et les égarments de la société.
Et c'est seulement quand nous sommes capables de penser pour nous-mêmes vers l'âge de seize ans que nous investiguons, disons, les connaissances que nous avons reçues.
Cependant, les outils que nous avons à nos dispositions ont été donnés par la culture dans laquelle nous vivons.
C'est très difficile de pouvoir analyser.
Nous sommes, disons, confinés dans une boîte.
Nous ne pouvons pas être hors de la boîte pour constater que nous sommes à l'intérieur de la même boîte.
Ça, c'est la position du Bodhisattva avant son illumination, avant son éveil.
Quand il a pris conscience de la souffrance humaine, disons, la maladie, la mort,
Il a essayé de trouver une solution, disons, à la condition humaine.
Et pour lui, la question était, vous savez, pourquoi nous souffrons ?
Maintenant, cela, bien sûr, était une question très forte.
Et ça, c'est une investigation très puissante par les existentialistes.
Vous devrez savoir les œuvres d'Albert Camus.
Il a écrit « Le mythe de Sisyphus ».
Sisyphe a été condamné au enfer parce qu'il a commis une faute dont le Vénérable ne se rappelle pas.
Alors, il a été condamné à...
transporter un rocher, disons, en haut d'une montagne afin qu'après le rocher, disons, redescende de nouveau.
Et il doit recommencer tout sans cesse comme ça, sans même avoir le temps de prendre une tasse de thé.
Pour Albert Camus, c'est une métaphore représentative de la condition humaine.
La vie devient absurde si vous êtes confronté à la mort.
Alors, quand une femme riche meurt, les gens proposent la question, disons, à l'avocat ou au notaire, disons, combien elle laisse en héritage.
L'avocat répond tout, elle laisse tout.
C'est le problème.
Nous travaillons dur toute notre vie et puis nous mourons.
Le problème c'est que nous avons travaillé durement toute notre vie et quand on meurt...
Le Bouddha aussi est confronté à ce problème et à cette question, pourquoi on souffre ?
Lui-même était
confiné dans la boîte de la société.
Et il est allé chercher les maîtres qui lui enseignaient
Mais, le lendemain, il se réveillait encore plus déprimé.
Donc, ces magnifiques états du Ciel où il n'y avait pas de souffrance semblaient aussi souffrir du problème de l'impermanence.
Mais, disons, les états célestes qu'il a atteints souffrent du même handicap, disons, de la souffrance, de l'impermanence.
Par le désespoir, il abandonne ses compagnons.
Vous vous rappelez de l'histoire que le Bouddha était assis à la croisée du chemin, disons malheureux, et qu'une dame qui s'appelle Sujata était venue lui présenter un bol de riz, de pouding, oui.
Un gâteau de riz.
Qu'est-ce que c'est ?
Qu'est-ce que c'est du riz ?
Un gâteau de riz ?
Non, non, non.
C'est de la semoule.
Semoule.
C'est comme une soupe.
Un potage de riz.
Le pouding n'est pas un potage.
Le pouding est un cake.
Pudding is not ok.
Porridge.
Porridge, there we are.
Porridge of rice.
Only the British know this.
Only the British know the enlightening effect of rice pudding.
Seulement les Britanniques connaissent l'effet de l'évêque.
De l'évêque.
Alors, quand il a mangé son potage de riz, il est revigoré.
Alors, à ce moment-là, il se rappelait qu'il avait assisté enfant à la cérémonie des labours qui était effectuée par son père.
La manière dont il a observé son père labourer le chant lui donna la confiance de trouver la solution à la cessation de la souffrance humaine.
Avant cela, disons, il est assumé que vous pourrez créer un état céleste en créant en vous-même cet état-là.
C'est comme si quand vous êtes malheureux vous pourriez acheter une glace et à ce moment-là vous serez heureux.
à partir disons de la méditation de l'amour universel vous pourrez vous sentir bien heureux
le désespoir est venu.
Maintenant
Quand il était assis sous l'arbre Bodhi, il commençait à pratiquer, disons, une méthode qui n'a jamais été enseignée auparavant.
Et ce qu'il faisait, c'était, au lieu d'essayer de faire quelque chose avec la tête et le cœur, il les observait.
En les observant, il a commencé à réaliser comment il avait créé son propre souffrance.
En l'observant, disons, son cœur et son esprit, il a constaté comment il avait créé lui-même ses souffrances.
En constatant comment il avait créé ses propres souffrances, il peut maintenant les dénouer.
disons, quelque chose de magique est arrivé, il a constaté que s'il observe, disons, tous ces états,
Ces états mentaux se sont curés.
Quand il observe juste l'angoisse, l'angoisse mourra.
Il n'a pas besoin de faire rien.
Il n'a rien, disons, à intervenir.
Il n'a même pas besoin d'aller chercher une thérapie.
C'est très bon marché.
Il a découvert deux choses.
La première chose, c'est qu'en observant l'esprit, l'esprit se calme.
Le cœur se guérit.
En découvrant une nouvelle relation avec son esprit il a découvert un état, disons, de calme permanent
Cet esprit, cet esprit, les émotions et cet esprit ne sont pas moi, pas moi.
Pas moi, pas moi.
Quelqu'un, disons, se plaint auprès du Bouddha que, disons, l'entraînement est très dur.
Et il a dit, oui, c'est vrai.
Mais, à la fin de cet entraînement, vous allez obtenir le Nibbana.
Et le questionnaire a dit, Nibbana ?
Donc quoi ?
Et puis le Nibbana, et puis encore, et puis alors.
Et quand vous allez atteindre le Nibbana, vous allez être content et heureux.
Et puis il commence à décrire son propre expérience.
Il est content et avec ça heureux.
et il est content lui-même et heureux.
Cet état de contentement est un état où il n'y a aucun désir.
C'est un type de désir, disons, particulier qui est basé sur le moi.
Le sentiment de soi est basé sur une sensation d'insécurité et l'insécurité c'est qu'il y a la mort.
Et l'insécurité provient, disons, du spectre de la mort Alors nous constatons dans notre vie qu'il y a toujours une base, disons, d'anxiété
A cause de cette anxiété, nous devrons faire de telle sorte que nous nous sentons en sécurité.
Qu'est-ce que vous exigez de votre gouvernement ?
la sécurité la sécurité disons contre les ennemis de l'extérieur la sécurité disons contre les crises économiques correct
Après ça, on peut devenir riche.
Ça ne vaut pas la peine d'être riche si vous allez, disons, être attaqué.
Nous avons le sentiment que plus nous prétendons les biens, plus nous nous sentons en sécurité.
Nous nous sentons beaucoup plus en sécurité si nous avons un million de francs dans notre compte bancaire que 10 francs.
Notre vie poussée par la peur, par l'anxiété, disons, consiste à posséder les biens.
Non seulement les biens matériels comme la télévision ou bien l'argent, mais aussi les amis.
Beaucoup d'amis me rendent, disons, sécurisés.
Beaucoup de pouvoir me sécurise.
Les riches, les fameux et les puissants
C'est ce que nous aimons être.
Et puis, vers lors, nous nous sentirons en sécurité.
Le Bouddha parlait de la convoitise, mais c'est plus dans le sens de l'acquisition, de la possession.
La convoitise, disons, ne se manifeste seulement que quand on le fait aux dépens de quelqu'un d'autre, d'autrui.
Plus on se sent insécurisé, moins on est généreux.
Ça, c'est un aspect.
L'autre aspect, c'est que pour que je me sente en sécurité, il faudrait que je me débarrasse de mes ennemis.
A lack of money, lack of friends who don't like me, who suddenly don't like me, I...
qui commencent à me détester.
Tout ce qui sabote ou bien mine ma sécurité, mes possessions, sont considérées comme mes ennemis.
Oui.
Si je peux m'en débarrasser ou bien les anéantir, à ce moment-là, je le ferai.
Et si je n'arrive pas, à ce moment-là, je me sauve.
Et à ce moment-là, je suis en contact avec ma peur fondamentale.
Et quand nous prenons, disons, sous l'aspect du corps, nous nous soucions beaucoup de notre santé, une obsession, disons, pour notre santé,
légitimes des millions et des millions de francs dépensés sur les vitamines crèmes médecine alternative moi aussi
Disons, pour me maintenir en vie.
Disons, quand par exemple, si je suis menacé dans ma santé ou bien menacé dans ma...
disons, intégrité physique, quelqu'un qui m'attaque, mon attitude ce sera de l'aversion, du rejet, de la peur.
Cette attitude provient de l'égarement du soi qui perpétue dans toute notre existence
Et tout cela est basé sur le non-savoir.
À travers la méthode vipassana, c'est-à-dire la vision pénétrante et analytique,
nous allons savoir ce qui est, comment les choses sont si nous appréhendons, comprenons vraiment l'impermanence l'impermanence dans le monde extérieur, l'impermanence en nous-mêmes
à ce moment-là nous pouvons voir qu'il n'y a rien qui mérite que l'on s'accroche oui, à quoi on s'accroche ?
à quoi on s'accroche ?
oui il n'y a rien dans le monde qui mérite qu'on s'accroche c'est ce que le Bouddha dit, hein ?
Il n'y a rien dans le monde qui mérite qu'on s'accroche.
Nous devrons nous le répéter tout le temps.
Qu'est-ce que c'est ?
Si quelqu'un vous vole votre voiture ou votre télévision ou autre chose, il y aura un sentiment de colère
Disons que quelqu'un nous dépossède.
En plus, il y a la tristesse de la perte de l'objet.
Après, il y aura l'anxiété, le souci si on peut récupérer la chose ou bien être compensé par l'assurance.
Nous ne savons pas combien nous sommes attachés à telle ou telle chose jusqu'au moment où nous la perdons.
Vous pouvez dire à vos amis que vous pourrez vivre sans votre voiture.
Mais quand quelqu'un vous vole, à ce moment-là vous ne pourrez pas vivre sans votre voiture.
pour priser cet égarment, disons, de possession, de propriété.
Pour comprendre, disons, cet égarment, il faudrait
comprendre que la propriété est un concept légal mais quand le voleur prend possession de ma voiture disons, elle devient sa voiture si je peux comprendre que
Posséder quelque chose est une illusion.
La seule chose que je peux faire avec un objet, c'est l'utiliser.
Si quelqu'un me vole quelque chose, j'aurais dû lui offrir l'objet avec pleine compassion.
Peut-être qu'il a besoin de l'objet plus que moi.
Il y a l'histoire d'un maître zen qui s'assied tout seul sur un rocher.
Et un voleur vient et lui dépouille de tous ses vêtements.
Et quand le meurtre est parti, il a regardé à la lune et il a dit, ah, si seulement je lui avais donné la lune.
et quand le voleur est parti le maître contemple la lune et dit si seulement je pourrais lui aussi lui offrir la lune si nous comprenons comment les choses sont à ce moment-là nous pourrons
disons, diminuer notre moi.
Disons
Comment ça s'appelle ?
Ce sentiment de mon possession, nous devons l'intégrer en nous-mêmes.
Cette voiture, disons, ses émotions ne sont ni moi et ne m'appartiennent pas.
Nous devons arrêter de posséder ces états mentaux.
Comment la propriété se manifeste avec ces états mentaux ?
Quand, disons, des états mentaux superbes, disons comme l'amour, disons, agréable, survient dans notre esprit, nous les saisissons.
Et quand quelque chose de mauvais apparaît, quelque chose comme la dépression, l'anxiété, alors nous voulons l'annihiler.
Donc, notre problème, c'est comment être avec ce qui est beau dans une façon non attachée, non graspée.
Le problème, c'est comment...
être avec les choses belles sans les saisir sans les désirer ce n'est pas parce que nous voulons détruire ce qui est beau nous ne voulons pas que ce qui est beau va nous causer une souffrance ce qui nous cause la souffrance
C'est la manière dont nous, disons, c'est notre relation avec ces choses-là.
De notre côté, nous voulons, disons, éliminer la souffrance de la douleur.
La douleur est naturelle, disons, est un état naturel pour le corps.
Aussi longtemps que nous avons, nous possédons un corps, nous avons...
Donc ce que nous essayons de découvrir est une relation avec la douleur qui ne cause pas de souffrance.
Et quand il s'agit de douleur émotionnelle, c'est la même chose.
Il en est de même avec des douleurs émotionnelles.
Comment peut-on traiter les états mentaux comme dépression ?
disons l'anxiété disons de traiter de manière de ne pas en souffrir.
C'est ça que la méthode de la vision pénétrante va vous enseigner.
à ce moment-là nous pouvons l'intégrer dans nos vies de tous les jours lentement nous pouvons constater cette transformation tout d'abord le côté sombre
va disparaître parce que nous nous arrêtons de nous y complaire.
Et le côté brillant va se développer parce que nous n'y complaisons pas.
Par exemple, l'amour
L'amour va se développer naturellement, disons, vers que nous ne voulons pas le posséder.
L'amour, disons, est un cœur ouvert où nous nous soucions de l'autre.
Dès que
Bien que nous aimons, mais que nous voulons seulement nous rendre heureux, à ce moment-là, nous sommes en train de mettre une barrière autour de l'amour.
Mon amour pour autrui ne doit pas dépendre, disons, de ma sympathie vis-à-vis d'eux.
Nous apprécions quelqu'un, disons...
disons, ne dépend pas de la...
Oui.
L'amour doit être une attitude qui ne doit pas dépendre, disons, de ce qu'on aime, de ce qu'on apprécie ou non, la personne.
Qui aimant de nous.
Qui aimant.
Dans la roue de la coproduction conditionnelle, nous partons de cette base de ne pas savoir et nous faisons un erreur.
de la peur et nous commettons des erreurs.
La première erreur, l'erreur fondamentale, c'est de penser que nous sommes des êtres humains.
À ce moment-là, nous construisons tout un monde autour de nous pour justifier, disons, cette assertion.
Nous le faisons par, disons, par l'identification et par la possession.
Quand nous retournons à ce processus, quand nous retournons à ce processus et que nous commençons à détruire le erreur c'est pourquoi
C'est pourquoi tous les sentiments de culpabilité et de honte vont disparaître.
Parce qu'ayant commis des erreurs basées sur le non-savoir, en réalité nous sommes innocents.
C'est parce que nous avons fait des erreurs que nous avons commis des offenses aux autres.
Le processus, c'est de partir de non-savoir à l'égarement,
de la délusion, nous passons à des actions sans compétence puis nous créons cette souffrance et à un moment dans nos vies, nous nous disons à nous-mêmes
Et à partir d'un certain moment, nous nous posons la question pourquoi nous souffrons.
Et c'est la raison pour laquelle nous nous engageons à méditer.
Ou certaines formes de pratiques spirituelles.
Et à ce moment-là, nous allons, disons,
entre dans un processus horrible de dénouer tout ce procédé.
Et au lieu d'être ignorant, nous allons devenir sages.
Et au lieu d'être ignorant,
dans l'innocent dans le non-savoir nous nous devenons et nous devenons purs avec la sagesse et un corps pur nous allons manifester notre compassion pour autrui
Ça, c'est notre destin.
Mais nous ne pouvons pas espérer un progrès notable, disons, dans une période de 25 ans.
25 ans ?
Ou plus !
J'espère que je suis quelqu'un d'aide pour vous et que vous serez libéré plus tôt que plus tard.